[Musik]
sagt zum feuer sind die beiden elemente
um diese den neuen film von werner
herzog sorten feier delegation von
wissenschaftlern aus der ersten welt wie
man das vielleicht früher gelernt hat
kommt in ein lateinamerikanisches land
dessen name nicht genannt wird und
möchte dort eine botschaft verbreiten
nämlich dass die menschheit im begriff
ist ihre eigenen lebensgrundlagen zu
zerstören
es beginnt aber schon am flughafen alles
anders zu verlaufen als diese delegation
es sich erwartet hat
es ist hier los wir sind diese männer
erst auf umwegen computern an den
eigentlichen schauplatz des films eine
spektakuläre salzwüste in bolivien
[Musik]
und dort beginnt die geschichte noch
einmal ein bisschen von neuem denn dort
wird die deutsche wissenschaftlerin lara
sommerfeld die von veronica ferres
gespielt wird mehr oder weniger
ausgesetzt und hat einen sehr besonderes
ökologisch bedeutsame es eben auch
wieder ein abenteuer mit dem werner
herzog den film noch einmal eine ganz
andere note gibt und was die hauptrolle
wird von der deutschen star
schauspielerin veronica ferres gespielt
bei der man sofort ein bisschen daran
denkt dass herzog seinen letzten film
königin der wüste mit der amerikanischen
super star schauspielerin nicole kidman
gemacht hat eine frau ähnlichen typs nun
hat er eben veronica ferres besetzt
woraus man schließen könnte das entweder
weniger geld hatte oder das eben etwas
anderes vorhatte in diesem fall ganz
eindeutig ging es ihm darum veronica
ferres mit schauspielern eines typs
zusammen zu bringen die nicht obliegt
sofort so mittelbar zu ihr passen da es
einerseits der mexikanische jungs da
gabriel garcía bernal der eine sehr
komische rolle in dem film übernommen
hat wir brauchen durch lukas talente und
genug wasser treffen und eine vollbusige
die getränke bringt
und ein paar in bester lage und das joch
der wiesenflächen die eigentlich
interessante chemie endlich mit dem
männlichen zweiten hauptdarsteller
michael shannon ein hochinteressanter
schauspieler sind wieder geheimdienste
noch regierung im spiel und es wird auch
nichts mit dhl oder ähnlichem zu tun wir
sind sie dann professor ich schon immer
geschätzt wobei diese drei menschen
kopiert herzog noch eine ganze reihe von
anderen staaten erscheinungen so dass
insgesamt ständig dieser gesamteindruck
sich zunehmend verstärkt was ist das
eigentlich für ein film wo geht darum
was kann da noch kommen ist das ernst
gemeint man weiß es nicht haben decken
toilettenpapier und ein gaskocher
aber in dieser absurdität gewitter für
den qualitäten die wirklich
außergewöhnlich und einzigartig sind im
heutigen kino und aus diesem grund würde
ich sagen dass wenn man ein bisschen
großzügig ist mit dem regisseur wenn man
ein bisschen bereitet sich auf seine
exzentrik einzulassen
damit kommt man es mit einem
einzigartigen und wirklich sehenswerten
viel zu tun
[Musik]